like a message in a bottle on the
rolling tight sea of thieves sweeps onto
the shores of 2017 full of mystery and
promise all the new features of update
zero point one point one mean that
players packed for our next play taste
face the dangers of an expanded world
and a skeletal uprising as they venture
far across the open sea
[Music]
back in December we let 1,000 lucky and
sailors roam free on our varsity and
since then that pool of players has only
grown as we've pushed back the
boundaries of our world
you and your fellow rascals will now
find many more places to plunder
how many more nobody knows well we do
but there's no point spoiling it is
though within this indeterminately
larger world players will discover new
islands presenting new challenges and
opportunities one may come with a Hidden
Cove to anchor in safety while you
shovel up loot another mate later form a
daring getaway after grabbing another
crews gold just look before you leave as
fall damage is no definitely a thing
more islands also mean more outposts
increasing your options for hustling
chess safely back to the ship tree this
should make it easier to avoid the
ganking that some of you here doing our
for Sunday which is how the kill can
refer to treasure related blunderbuss
entities while you're off adventuring
make sure you don't let your guard down
not with the rattling remains of
long-forgotten pirates prowling the
islands they may be gutless and strictly
biological terms but these old scallywag
will Stoke on great at you with rusty
guns blazing so your crew members need
to watch each other's backs so that's
our latest update there's still so much
more to come but for now we hope you can
join us to search and skirmish your
merry way through the new wider world
see
Cheers
[Music]
you
[Music]